una búsqueda que no cesa hace siete años
tranquilina busca a su hija que
desapareció una tarde de septiembre en
cuernavaca capital del estado de morelos
en méxico más de ellos sueños con
abrazarla besarla escuchar su voz
tranquilina hace parte de uno de los 160
colectivos repartidos por todo méxico
dedicados a la búsqueda de desaparecidos
es muy duro pensar en un féretro en que
ya no voy a ver su sonrisa en que ya no
voy a ver sus ojos pero a final de
cuentas tengo fe tengo mucha fe que la
voy a encontrar y la pongo en las manos
de dios y pues que me la mande como como
él quiera como como esté mi bebé pero
que pero yo necesito saber qué fue de
ella con solo dos millones de habitantes
morelos es relativamente pequeño pero
está rodeado de estados que han luchado
contra la violencia 90% de los crímenes
quedan impunes es justamente para tratar
de evitar estas situaciones pero la
verdad es que si es algo que nos ha
rebasado esta es plenamente de peso
pleno y visto a todas luces pero pero si
nosotros como autoridades hemos estado
haciendo pues lo propio lo propio que un
municipio puede ofrecerle en méjico
según la comisión nacional de búsqueda
las desapariciones llegan a las 93 mil
desde que iniciaron los registros en
1964 en el último año la cifra de
desaparecidos ha crecido más del 20 por
ciento la violencia que azota el país
hace más de una década es ocasionada por
la guerra de los cárteles de la droga
los gobiernos anteriores incluido el de
andrés manuel lópez obrador han
intentado combatir las mafias sin éxito